all right pftpm tuesday edition as
always we do awards in this spot we
don't have shireen today we don't know
what to do technologically we're putting
up all sorts of different possibilities
here but it's just mds in me while
shireen and the rest of the selectors
continue to grind through
the 18-person potential hall of fame
class although the most to get in will
be eight mds how's it going today
it's going well missing shireen but you
know better her than us sitting through
that long meeting
you know people ask me all the time do
you wish you had a vote on the hall of
fame committee and i can say this
acknowledging number one that they'll
never give me one but number two that is
the last way i would want to spend eight
and a half hours or more on a tuesday
when there's work going on so shireen
thank you for being the one to do it
okay let's get down to it the offensive
player of the week defensive play of the
week rookie of the week and coach of the
week for the divisional round just the
two of us today mds let's start with
offensive player of the week who do you
have
well i have aaron rodgers and he was
just so cool and methodical and i never
once thought it was in doubt that he was
just going to move the ball at will
against a good rams defense now granted
a rams defense where aaron donald was at
less than 100 healthy but i just thought
that aaron rodgers could do whatever he
wanted the stats are right there he had
296 passing yards two touchdowns a
rushing touchdown he had no
interceptions no sacks no fumbles he he
barely had
any negative play of any kind
um you know i mean he had some
incompletions what more can you say he
he was outstanding in that game i got
one of his best games of an mvp
yeah and the touchdown run with the pump
fake was awesome everything he did was
awesome and it's a rams defense that
came into the game as one of the best in
the nfl and they look like anything but
against aaron rodgers and company i'm
going with stefan diggs you know it was
hard to find another one tom brady
didn't have a great game statistically
and i think the defense had a lot to do
with the tampa bay buccaneers winning
the game but diggs had over 100
receiving yards against the defense with
a great secondary they didn't lock
marlon humphrey up on him all game long
maybe they should have maybe they should
have doubled him all game long he had
six catches 106 yards on eight targets
and a touchdown
proving yet again that
he's the guy that boosted this team to
the next level that they were already a
playoff team without him but one of the
reasons they're playing this weekend is
the impact of stefan diggs and the
ability to get the ball to him even when
playing a team that has
the the manpower to take digs away they
still weren't able to do it
yeah and
you know it really
was
probably
the the one of the the lesser
performances i think from the bill's
offense but stefan diggs is is such a
difference maker that was one of those
games where you really do look at it and
you wonder
would they be here if they had not made
that trade
yeah absolutely okay defensive player of
the week for the division around mds who
do you have
well i'm sticking with the bills and as
i said it wasn't one of their better
games overall from their offense but but
the biggest play of that game came from
tehran johnson who had that 101 yard
interception return for a touchdown that
really just completely changed the game
it looked like it was about to be 10 to
10
and the next thing you know it's 17 to 3
it was a
almost a 14 point swing in that it
looked like the ravens were about to
score seven and then the bill scored
seven um it after that play
it was never in doubt was going to win
before that play it looked like a game
that was going to go down to the white
yeah that was the turn out the lights
moment for me there was still plenty of
time for the ravens to get back into it
but when you got 17-3 at that stage of
the game
the notion of the ravens suddenly
pulling out two touchdowns is is a long
shot and then lamar jackson gets injured
and that was that it was over and it was
that 14 point swing from the toront
johnson
touchdown return that made all the
difference for me
the defensive player of the week is
devin white of the tampa bay buccaneers
i've been praising him all week and for
good reason he was in the first half
a force
uh he he he not that he tried to do it
on purpose but his hit on deontay harris
knocked harris out of the game and
that's what happens when a guy who's not
very big isn't just returning punts and
kickoffs he's out there playing offense
he runs into a guy like devin white and
you may end up not being able to
continue again not that he did it on
purpose but it's that physicality he
brings to the position that seems rare
in today's nfl he's physical he's
intimidating but he doesn't cross the
line he's got controlled aggression
where he goes just far enough but he
pulls it back in and doesn't get a
15-yard penalty and then in the second
half
his recovery of the jared cook fumble it
looked so easy and we just think oh yeah
ball's bouncing around he's a
professional athlete he should be able
to scoop it up how many times have we
seen defensive players freak out when
that ball's popping around and the next
thing you know the offense recovers it
because they're trying to pick it up and
run with it and it bounces off their
hand and it ricochets over here and
that's one of the things i love about
the shape of the football you never know
where it's going to go he caught it
clean and he was gone and that allowed
the buccaneers to tie the game up and
then his interception allowed the
buccaneers to blow the game open if he
plays like he played in the second half
for the next eight quarters for the
buccaneers they're winning the super
bowl the question is can he keep playing
like that all right rookie of the week
mbs you got a guy who has a a pretty
clear connection to the moment where
devin white picked up that fumble
yes i do you and i were thinking the
same thing on that devin white play as
i'm watching that play with the employee
this guy could just as easily be an
offensive player if you know his high
school football coach had told him to
play running back or tight end he'd be
in the nfl on offense that's just the
kind of all-around football player he is
but my choice for rookie of the week was
actually the guy who forced that very
fumble you were just talking about and
that's antoine winfield jr that was such
an impactful play that i'm glad we're
mentioning both players who were
involved in it but it was kind of funny
to hear bruce arians talking this week
and taking a little bit of a shot at
chase young of the washington football
team and saying that antoine winfield jr
really deserves to be the defensive
rookie of you i don't know if i would
say that if we're really talking about
the totality of the season but antoine
winfield has had a great year he has
started all 18 games now for the
buccaneers he's had a big impact and i'm
going to be excited to see
when aaron rodgers goes picking on a
rookie cornerback is antoine winfield
ready for the best quarterback in the
league in the biggest game of his very
young career i think that's going to be
one of the real interesting things to
watch this week
i love the determination from antoine
winfield especially because he had a
shot at an interception just a few plays
before that he seemed even more
motivated to make something happen all
right for me it's tyler johnson rookie
of the week the guy who made that
incredible spinning lunging catch on
third and 11 on the drive that
ultimately gave the buccaneers the lead
23 to 20. mds who do you have for your
coach of the week
i i was so impressed with andy reid the
way he coached after patrick mahomes got
hurt
andy reed has a great track record of
that
whether it's last year when mahomes got
hurt in the regular season whether it's
with the eagles when donovan mcnabb got
hurt great job by andy reid
and actually andy reid earlier today was
one of my goats of the week because of
running patrick mahomes on third and one
so he gets a bad award and a good award
for me the coach of the week i got to
give it to todd bowles for what he did
with that defense he had them ready to
go without that defense we're talking
about the saints playing this week not
the tampa bay buccaneers all right thank
you mds we're going to take a break when
we return we'll open up the mailbag more
pftpm right after this
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports